>>Sean Lynch: Hey, guys.
My name is Sean Lynch.
I'm the Product Manager on Google App Engine.
And today, I have with me a sort of fairly
complete cross section of the App Engine Engineering
team.
Before I go on, do you guys want to introduce
yourselves and say which component you're
working on?
>>Taylor: Hey, I'm Taylor.
I work on a number of things, mainly Task
Queue and Chrome systems.
>>Kevin Gibbs: And I'm Kevin Gibbs.
I'm the Tech Lead and Manager for the App
Engine Team.
Do a little bit of everything.
And I’ll also mention this is a fireside
chat which I think is a great thing about
Google I/O.
It means that you guys are just here to ask
questions and we're gonna answer them and
hang out.
So, of course, use Moderator, but also, don't
hesitate to ask questions, or keep it real,
or ask us the hardest questions you can think
of because we just wanna connect with you
guys and help out.
>>Alfred Fuller: Hi, I'm Alfred Fuller.
I work on the Datastore and I do a lot of
the query stuff and, yeah, if you wanna have
y-, to know a lot about that, there’s a
talk tomorrow about the query stuff but I
will answer any questions you have now and
hopefully not to give too much of it away.
[Alfred laughs]
>>Max Ross: That's it, Alfred is the query
planner.
My name is Max Ross--
>>Kevin: [inaudible] gets better--
>>Max: I work on the Datastore with Alfred
and I do anything else that's related to Java.
>>Brett Slatikin: Brett-, Brett Slatkin.
I work on the Runtime and APIs team.
>>Guido van Rossen: Guido van Rossen.
Anything Python related, the admin console,
the domain console, and then App Engine for
business that was demoed this morning during
the keynote.
[pause]
>>Dan Sanderson: I'm Dan Sanderson.
I'm the Technical Writer Lead for App Engine.
I also wrote that book that's upstairs.
>>Brett: For sale in your local bookstore.
>>Sean: And there's actually, I think, one
or two other app engineers floating around
in the crowd there so you may see them join
us up on stage if you ask a particularly hot
button question.
So, that's, that's it.
Oh, two quick things, yeah -- there's a microphone
there.
Please feel free to line up and ask questions.
It's probably if you're going to, you can,
if you're going to ask a particularly interesting
one, then that's a great place to do it.
If you do come up and ask, it would be great
if you could give us just your name and your
company.
I suspect that we've worked with a couple
of you on email, or on the groups, or on IRC
over the last few years.
So, so it would be really cool if we could
put the name to the face.
Otherwise, I think, yeah, I'm just going to
be reading questions from the Moderator and
we'll be taking questions from the mic.
>>Kevin: [inaudible]
>>Sean: And there's a, there's a couple of
empty seats up here in the front that's got
the placards on that.
Feel free, yeah, come join us.
>>Kevin: [inaudible]
>>maleaudience: Do you know the Moderator
URL?
>>Sean: It should be, if you go to the Session
page on I/O, it should be embedded in the
Wave.
But I'll, I'll try and post it up as well
here.
Yeah, I know.
[laughs]
>>Kevin: Why don't you read the question,
Sean?
>>Sean: Actually, we've got one up front.
>>Max1: Hi, I'm Max from IBM Research.
Do -- is your Sequel support gonna be full
Sequel or will it include transactions?
>>Kevin: Read the question.
>>Sean: Sure. So, the question if I heard
correctly was, is the Sequel support gonna
be full Sequel or just--
>>Max1: and will it support transactions?
>>Sean: Will it support transactions?
>>Max1: I guess, elaborate a little bit on
the Sequel support that you're planning.
>>Sean: Yeah. Full Sequel support will include
transactions.
>>Max1: I mean, is it gonna be like a Google
Sequel--
>>Kevin: Yes.
>>Max1: as well?
>>Kevin: Definitely.
So, you know that, that support's really coming
together right now and I don't have a lot
of details about it.
We don't know what all the details will be.
But, what I can tell you is it is based on
real Sequel databases, real Sequel servers,
and the features that you expect from Sequel.
It's not just a query language or just in
a tiny feature.
It's really, what I think you guys would all
believe is very familiar Sequel.
Now, I can't guarantee that like, every esoteric
feature, if you've used it there and some
may be particularly challenging, things like
triggers, things like that.
But, I think that it's something that any
of you would definitely recognize as a standard,
traditional Sequel database server.
>>Max1: Will it scale like a Datastore?
>>Sean: Will it scale like a Datastore?
>>Kevin: As much as Sequel scales. So I mean--
[audience laughs]
>>Kevin: what I just said.
I would be lying to you if I said that it
-- I could also magically scale because the
reasons why Sequel databases have trouble
scaling are natural reasons based on their
design.
It's not that Sequel database programmers
didn't write it well.
It's, it's just that those are the limitations
of a design like that.
So, I would expect that you would have the
same set of issues you might have with the
standard Sequel database that you would run
yourself.
I think the differences are that you don't
have to run it yourself.
Well, keep it running will make it available
to you and if you need to scale that, you
probably would use similar strategies that
you use today in other hosting environments;
sharding, using multiple Sequel databases,
and things like that.
>>Max1: But we don't, will we have to manage
this or you manage this in RBF?
>>Sean: Will we have to manage it ourselves?
>>Kevin: Because some of those are getting
a little, it's a little too soon for me to
say because management can mean a lot of different
things. So, I don't want to overpromise--
>>Max1: Well, like sharding.
It's, it's -- you mentioned sharding.
So, will, will it go through a shard?
>>Kevin: Oh, no I don't believe that there
will be anything that does the sharding automatically
for you.
I think that's something that's too natural,
what you're actually doing.
But, being perfectly honest with you, I think
it's too soon to say about some of this.
But, I think the best way for you to think
about it is that it's a Sequel server that
you can turn on and use.
But I mean -- Max maybe there’s something
you want to say about it?
>>Max: This microphone's working.
The only, the only thing that I would add
is, I, I definitely recognize that there's
lots of pain points associated with sharding
and I don't feel like anybody has really addressed
those in a way that, that removes all those
pain points yet.
And that's something we should certainly look
at but I think, as Kevin said, we don't want
to get ahead of ourselves here.
Right now, we don't have a Sequel offering
that you can use today.
And so, the first step for us is to do the
work to make that happen so that you have
a basic Sequel offering that you can use today.
And then, for the more advanced stuff, we'll
take it as far as we can go.
But, the other thing I would add is if you
find yourself in a position with your Sequel
database where it's not scaling for you, you
do have this other thing called the Datastore,
which has been around for a couple years now
and works really well and scales really well.
So, you have more options at your disposal
than you otherwise would.
>>Max1: I'm taking a lot of time, but this
is my last comment.
So, there's a lot of criticism about this.
I mean, I'm coming from a, a company that
provides a solution in Sequel so, and I'm
not trying to defend this because I, I'm from
research and I can tell you that part of the
reason why you're probably doing it is because
customer's asking for it, and it's because
they have existing application, and it's because
it works.
It doesn't scale, maybe, to the extent that
Datastore does, but it provides certain guarantees,
and why?
Because it has a solid mathematical foundation
behind it and 20 years of research.
So, there is advantages to a model like this
and, and I thought what, what you were getting
at is something more like Sequel Azure, where
you would try to provide some level of, of
scaling with that, but, that's fine.
Just a comment.
>>Sean: Just before we go on, I want to get
our two new additions to introduce themselves.
>>Don Schwartz: Hi, I'm Don Schwartz. I work
on App Engine, primarily Java support.
>>Toby Reyelts: Hi, I'm Toby Reyelts and I
do the same.
>>maleaudience2: Good timing, then.
So, I was very excited last year when you
guys announced the Java support on App Engine,
and been advocating it to many people as a
solution.
At the same time, I'm embracing the, the Groovy
and Grails metaphor because I'm kind of jealous
of the Ruby guys.
So, we built this entire thing on Groovy on
Grails for the App Engine, but it doesn't
work because there's a 30 second time limit
in there that by the time that the, the Grails
initializes, you basically run out of time.
And I know in the roadmap, there's plans for
having a ability to reserve instance or keep
it running, which would be very, very useful
except I just don't see you guys implementing
it.
And it keep -- seems like you're going to
tangents and now you have this App Engine
enterprise, which to me is a bad news because
to me it sounds like it's distraction rather
than finishing that and doing it really, really
well for the Java people.
Now you're kind of expanding and you're kind
of making yourself very thin.
And I see it now the trend is agains-, across
all the Google different things. You do so
many different things and do you half good;
you're not doing any of them great.
So, I guess my point is what's your plan for
the Java support?
Are you gonna be able to support it, or should
we just leave and go to Amazon or some other
solution?
Thank you.
[audience boos]
>>Sean: We said, "Ask the tough ones."
[audience laughs]
>>Sean: So, is it fair to say your question
is are we gonna continue to add the, or additional
support for Java with reserved instances--
>>maleaudience2: [inaudible]
>>Sean: I, I, I completely hear you. Do you
want to tackle this one?
>>Kevin: [inaudible]
[audience laughs]
>>Sean: Are we focusing on reserved instances
in Java?
I think, I, I'll jump on it.
We have probably just an equal, equivalent
representation up here on stage between Python
and Java.
So, in terms of language support, I don't
think that we're spreading ourselves too thin.
I think that we've actually got it very covered.
We definitely hear that reserved instances,
or the, or the feature that we have on our
roadmap there is, is particularly painful.
Not just for the guys who are trying to go
beyond Java and use other JVM based languages,
but even on the Python side, the guys are
running into it using particular frameworks.
So, it's, it's a pain point that we definitely
see and we're working hard to address it.
>>maleaudience2: [inaudible]
>>Sean: Right.
I, I think we would probably have something
to show you before the year is out.
[pause]
>>Kevin: I, I echo what Sean said.
It is a very acute problem.
We're very aware of it.
We are working on multiple solutions and that's
the big problem.
Some of them are already working internally;
some are being coded right now internally,
so I don't like to make predictions stronger
than that.
But,
I do know when we're got the code working
and ready, we try to get it out there as soon
as we can.
And believe me, I know, these guys know, Don
and Toby knows, it hurts right now.
It's a problem and so we, we know we have
to do something better and get it out there.
So, we're working on it as best we can.
>>Sean: One thing to point out is the stuff
on our roadmap is things that we're actually
working on, we are actively working on.
It doesn't make it onto the roadmap if we
just got a lot of feature requests about it.
They’re just things that we're actually
trying to build.
>>maleaudience2: [inaudible]
>>Sean: Oh.
[Sean laughs]
>>maleaudience2: [inaudible]
>>Sean: Well, I'm, I'm, I apologize.
[Sean laughs]
>>audiencemember3: [inaudible]
>>Sean: I, I think, so the question was basically,
"Are we walking away?"
Oh, you got it.
>>Kevin: Sorry, I got it.
I'm a little hard of hearing so it's some
trouble with the questions.
I definitely hear what you're saying.
And, you know what?
I was concerned about that in our messaging,
too.
Because I wanted you guys to know that both
of these things are really, critically important.
If you read what it says on the App Engine
for Business site, if you look at our FAQ,
if you look at some of the stuff, we emphasize
in the strongest words that we can -- how
committed we are both to App Engines that
exist today for highly scalable Internet consumer
sites for the platform that you guys have
all used, as well as the enterprise stuff
we're getting into now.
And what you heard me talk about today was
largely focused on intranet apps.
But, we also plan to, just in the same way,
and this is mentioned more in the docs, have
that same set of tools, that same thing that
we're building there appropriate for ISVs;
for people who are resigned, for people who
are just building businesses on App Engine
but want those same things.
Now, we, we're trying to take over the world.
We're trying to take on everything, every
single thing we can but we have to do it in
steps.
[audience chuckles]
So, we, it's something that we really care
about and particularly there is some language
about this.
There is some stuff you can read that I hope
it will instill you with confidence, but I
promise you that we are committed to both
of those sides and we're doing the best we
can to connect them.
>>Sean: All right -- third question now?
Is that what we're up to?
[Sean laughs]
>>audience3: This is the first question, I'm
sorry.
>>Sean: No, no.
It's fine.
>>audience3: Ok, this question is about Google
App Engines take on transactional installation
limits.
I, I understand that you, you say that you
support read committed, but typically in ACID-complaint
database, when you have read committed, when
you start a transaction and when you do updates,
when you read the same entity again what you
get is a modified entity.
Right?
But in the case of Google App Engine, after
you modify within a transaction's code, you
get the older entity, right, perhaps because
of distributed data's, too.
How do you, question number one, how do you
claim that this is read committed?
Number two, if you're building business applications
of some kind--
[audience member coughs]
of real-world application, how do you come
across, or how do you overcome this problem?
>>Max: So to answer the, to answer the first
part, correct me if I'm wrong, I believe we've
been careful in our language to say that the
closest isolation, or, sorry, the closest
thing to the existing, what are they?
The closest, the closest identifier to what
the Datastore has is read committed--
>>audience3: Right.
>>Max: But, it is not read committed in the
absolute sort of most generally agreed upon
sense and what you're describing is the way
in which it differs slightly.
We offer strong consistency, which means that
if in a transaction, you write your data,
you commit that transaction, you read it back,
you're going to get your data.
But, what you describe is a quirk and it is
an artifact of the implementation of, of how
we do things and I realize that it differs
a little bit from what you expect when you
say read committed.
But, read committed is the closest thing out
there to what we're doing.
So, I can, I, I sleep ok with that.
I apologize if it has confused you but I think
we've tried to be careful about not saying,
"Yes, this is read committed and that's all
you need to understand."
>>audience3: All right.
[Brett and Max talk back and forth without
microphones – inaudible]
>>Max: Yeah, that's fair.
So, I mean, how does, does, how does, how
does this impact you?
Did this, did this bite you in an unexpected
way?
>>audience3: Yeah.
For example, if you, if you're trying to build
up the system application, for example, and
let's say you have an inventory and you have
line items, you add a quantity for the particular
inventory.
Now, you do a sum of, or you credit all the
list of line items--
>>Max: Yeah.
>>audience3: within the same transaction,
what you get is a wrong number against a number
which is, I mean, I, I understand if it's
three-third ‘til you commit if you query
for a word like "Google IO", its ok to miss
that until commit happens, right?
But, if you are running a business transaction
and you want to do a sum and then based on
that, you want to do the next transaction,
whether the quantity has exceeded or not,
then you run into a problem, especially if
you're, if you're trying to uphold the same
JDO implementation, I think you will run into
the problem, right?
Am I making sense?
>>Max: Yeah I, yeah, I, I understand the scenario
you're talking about but I don't, I don't
have a magic bullet for you.
We can say, we can say things like you can
write your data and then you can do your querying
in a separate transaction and then you're
guaranteed you're gonna see that sort of thing,
but I realize that's not the most natural
way to approach that problem, especially if
you've been doing it with a relational database.
It's, it's one of those "gotchas" that's out
there and I'm, and I'm sorry that it bit you.
>>audience3: Can I ask a second question?
I'm sorry.
>>Kevin: I think it's not fair to everyone
else.
So, I'm sorry.
But back, Sean, you want to read two of the
highest voted Moderator questions?
>>Sean: Yeah, absolutely.
So, the first one is for you guys, "What would
say has been the biggest lesson learned since
GAs launched two years ago?"
What, what was the biggest lesson learned
since GAs launch two years ago?
>>Kevin: Oh! Well, that's a fun one.
I'll pass the mic around for that one.
Well I'll think.
You guys have an answer off the top of your
head you wanna say?
This is Alon.
>>Alon: Hi, hi my name is Alon.
I'd say one of the biggest lessons that we've
learned in terms of, the way we gen-, generate
our infrastructure and things is to keep everything
configurable because you never know how things
are going to be used, or where the pain points
are gonna be.
So, being able to have more knobs and, and
buttons to push and turn is really helpful.
[pause]
>>Taylor: On, on a similar note, I think one
of the things that I've picked up, compared
last year was that transparency is really
key.
So, it's really important for the developer
to able to see what's going on with their,
with their system.
[pause]
>>Kevin: I think something that is a lesson
learned, one that we saw a little bit coming,
but sometimes the, the hardest lessons are
the ones that you saw coming but you didn't
realize that it wasn't, it wasn't a cat running
at you; it was a tiger running at you in terms
of the scale of the problem and how bad, and
how acute the situation was.
It's in terms of the limits in App Engine.
I know a lot of these, especially in our first
year developing the App Engine, ma-, man,
those really stung and they were really hard
to work with whether it was ICP requests or
hitting quotas too soon or those sort of things.
And I hope you've seen, we've worked really
hard to clear those up and if you look at
our roadmap to the platform, we're working
really hard to clear out the rest of them,
too.
We knew those were gonna be bad.
I don't think it was apparent, at least to
me, just how bad some of those were.
So, we're trying to do everything we can to
make it better.
[pause]
[door squeak]
>>Brett: I guess the biggest thing I've learned
is the ridiculously crazy things you can build
with various, small amounts of tools.
Basically, I can use memcache to do almost
anything now I feel like.
[audience member laughs]
You can come to my talk tomorrow; I'll tell
you about it.
But, they're very small constructs – it
kind of goes along with what Alon was saying
about having more buttons and knobs.
There's a few very low-level constructs that
you can supply, like Task Queue, or a certain
level of transactionality, or massively parallel
gets, or list properties that give you a huge
amount of power with just some very small
tools.
And you can combine them together to create
even more complicated constructs in user space.
So, it's been really cool seeing what we can
build in user space, like Linux has futexes
and we have all of our other crazy stuff that's
kind of like that.
And we'll be showing a lot of it tomorrow
from some of the talks from me and Mike Aizatsky.
So, you should come check those out.
>>Sean: Yeah.
The next one is, "App Engine for Business
will support as itself for custom, top-level,
top-level domains.
It seems primarily geared towards enterprise
applications. Will it be available for non-enterprise
applications?
Public."
>>Kevin: Yes.
[audience laughs]
These features may be part of App Engine for
Business, but there will be a part about Engine
for Business that you can use for your business
applications that are for inside your company,
and for outside of your company.
So, you'll be able to use these in the situations
that you need.
The pricing for these features may be different
for you.
All of that is still being developed.
We don't have those things figured out, but
will you be able to use this to build the
sort of apps that you want to do?
Yes.
[pause]
>>Sean: Ok. Actually, let's grab another mic.
>>audience4: Hi. My question is about the
best approach for delivering sort of real-time
notifications to a Web application, especially
with new standards coming along, like WebSocket.
I know that might be somewhat at odds with
the model of how App Engine works, where you
can't have a socket open waiting for data
to flow.
And I saw a demo this morning with some of
the new GWT Widgets, the data presentation
widgets, and one thing I noticed that caught
my attention is they had sort of data pop-up
sort of on demand and that was running on
App Engine.
I wonder if you can talk about if there's
anything special going on there and how--
>>Sean: Yeah, sure.
>>audience4: and what's the best approach
to do that.
>>Sean: Thanks for your question; I'm really
happy you asked that.
I'll give you 5 dollars later.
[audience laughs]
>>Brett: So, tomorrow we have a session with
Brett Bavar and Moishe Lettvin on the App
Engine channel API, which is commenter browser
push as an API, the, and it reuses a lot of
the same structure we use at Google for long
polling or Comet in applications like Buzz
and Gmail.
And this is the idea of, with our XMPP API
you have a JID that you send messages to,
you'll be able to have an addressable channel
that you can send messages to in a deferred
manner, either during a request from a task
queue request, or however you want to address
it.
So, you can do all kinds of broadcast mechanisms
or direct messages between users and, basically,
everything you can wanna do like that.
The plan, so we're, so we're gonna be, we
talked about on the blog a little bit and
it's gonna be atrust the tester thing at first,
but we're getting along, along with getting
it out for everybody.
And the plan is to get it implemented in such
a way that under the covers we could replace
it with WebSockets, with absolutely no knowledge
from the application developer standpoint.
So, once the browser is capable of doing WebSockets,
instead of long polling over some weird, bidirectional
HTTP channel, it would just happen.
So, that's yes, yes, yes, and yes.
We're doing all those things and so you should
definitely come to Moishe's talk at 1 tomorrow
and you can also, and their talk, and basically
everyone is showing this off because it's
so great.
We all want it.
So, yes?
[applause]
>>Brett: Moishe's in the back if you want
to put his hand up.
That's, he's your man -- don't hurt him.
[audience chuckles]
>>Dave: So, hi, I'm Dave Peck,
I work with wallsquare.com.
And we love the URL fetch API.
We've been making heavy use of asynchronous
URL fetch but, unfortunately, it still doesn't
go far enough for us in some cases.
We run into the reality of systems that take
a very long time to respond, even with small
amounts of data.
So, we're wondering if you have plans to support
on your roadmap URL fetch with callba-, Webbook
style callbacks.
And sort of flip-side to that, URL fetch to
-- directly to the Blobstore.
[pause]
>>Sean: Sure.
So, the question was, do we ha-, are we planning
on support for URL fetch with some sort of
asynchronous callback?
>>Dave: Yes.
>>Sean: After it's complete, for long running,
minute, hour, however long it runs.
[pause]
>>Kevin: It's definitely something that we
are interested in.
We know it's an acute problem right now that
just doing URL fetch requests that go over
ten seconds, which, I mean, to me it doesn't
seem quite like a good idea that web services
often take longer than that, but the reality
is they do.
And some of them, I've, I've seen some that
like, they're supposedly take 30 minutes,
an hour, to return and that's a normal operation--
>>Dave: But
>>Kevin: which is unusual to me, but that's
how the way the world works.
>>Dave: Unfortunately--
>>Kevin: Both on the case of doing ones that
are just lon-, just a little bit longer, we
just need a little bit more room to grow and
ones that are a lot longer.
We're very aware of this, it's very much on
our mind and we're trying to do something
about it.
I think we might see some things in the sooner,
like the new return feature to help you get
a little bit further--
>>Dave: Okay.
>>Kevin: help you get more into the 30 second,
minute sort of range.
We also wanna do some stuff further out that
could allow it to be entirely indefinite for
whatever you're doing.
>>Dave: Right, and as far as URL fetching
directly to the Blobstore, is that something
that's on your radar screen, too?
We're talking the services that are handing
us data back that's in the dozens to hundreds
of megabytes.
>>Sean: So, you wanna URL fetch a blob out
of the Blobstore and keep it?
>>Dave: No, I'd like to URL fetch, perform
a URL fetch to a remote service and have its
results, assuming they're valid, end up directly
in the Blobstore.
>>Sean: Interesting. Will we support URL fetch
with the results directly into the Blobstore?
>>Dave: Yeah.
[stage chatter]
>>Brett: I mean, the, the gist of his answer
is that we're trying to figure out a way to
pipe everything into everything else.
>>Dave: Sure.
[audience laughs]
>>Brett: So, just take the combinatorial expansion,
every possible thing, yes we're trying to
do that.
>>Dave: Great.
>>Brett: I know, we want to do that ‘cause
it's natural and makes sense.
So, can I save the result of a Task-Queue-Task
in the Blob-, in the Blobstore?
Same question, right?
>>Dave: Right.
>>Brett: So, yeah, we're totally aware and
so we have nothing to say yet, but we know.
>>Dave: Great.
Thanks.
I won't ask about all the other permutations.
[audience chuckles]
[pause]
>>Chris: Hi.
Chris Handley, Space Telescope Science Institute.
As a heavy user and sometimes committer to
Numpy, I was wondering what we could do to
convince you to add it to the list of acceptable
Python libraries that we could use.
>>Sean: The question was, "Can we support
Numpy?"
>>Kevin: You know we get that question from
time to time.
We would like to.
It is difficult for us to support each one
of those libraries so it comes along like
that.
So, we don't have any plans at the moment
right now.
But, it's something that we need to hear more
from you guys so that we can find ways to
either get libraries like that working for
you, or to do something that allows you to
work around it; to give you another way to
achieve the same thing.
But, I know how popular Numpy is in the scientific
community and a lot of things that are going
on there.
And so, I think it's some-, it's something
that we need to hear more often.
So, the reality of, of the matter is that
things get done by engineering teams when,
when we're made aware of how important this
is to you and how acute it is.
So, please keep, keep asking.
I've heard it from you, and try to, try to
get us hearing more about that library and
others so we can get it together for you.
>>Chris: Well, I was gonna say, it's pretty
much critical to any of the scientific community
that, and we're resistant to work at getting
it into the core.
And I mean, we've, Guido has come out and
said that he doesn't even think it should
be in the core just because of the, the development
time frame of Numpy versus the core libraries
for Python.
So, I guess I'll just advocate for it being
added and tell all my friends to say, "Me,
too" on the plug list.
[pause]
>>Guido: We certainly hear you.
[audience laughs]
>>audience6: This question is on 2 best practices
that you recommend.
One, one the denormalization portion, where
you recommend--
>>Brett: [inaudible]
>>Sean: Yeah, sorry.
>>audience6: Two best practices that you recommend,
one on the denormalized key mine in bit table
and the other one is read performance better
than write performance?
Recommending more of reads rather than writes,
but, but I think the reality is when you have
a denormalized key mine, you repeat the data
and therefore, when one, when one entity changes,
you pretty much change the data in multiple
entities.
Which essentially means you'll have to write
more.
So, how do you deal with this conflict when,
when you, when you build real world applications?
>>Sean: So, let me see if I heard the question
right.
It was the best practices around eNom based
data?
>>audience6: de-, de-, denormalized data.
>>Sean: Denormalized data and, and I missed
the first part.
>>audience6: So, that's one.
The second one being write performance being
slower than read.
So-
>>Sean: And, and, and how to handle that when
your application is just realistically more
write-focused?
>>audience6: And not just that.
In a normal application, if your application
becomes more and more denormalized, --
>>Sean: I see.
>>audience6: then one, when one entity changes,
you essentially have to change in multiple
entities and therefore, you're essentially
increasing the number of writes.
>>Sean: Right.
So, the, the question is what are the best
practices around denormalized data and because
we're recommending denormalized, that causes
more writes, that's sort of in conflict with
our reads are better performance than writes.
What do you have to say?
>>Max: [laughs] So, it's a, it's a, it's a
tough spot if you want to, the more ways you
want to query your data, then the more ways
that you're gonna need to duplicate that data,
whether you're using our built-in indexes
in order to be able to get those scans or
whether you're building your own.
The denormalized data are basically you're
building indexes that you can scan yourself.
So, the more ways that you wanna slice and
dice your data, the more expensive your writes
are gonna become because that's more stuff
to maintain.
That's the trade off. I don't have any; I
don't have any magic for you with the Datastore,
right?
If you really need really, really flexible
querying, then you're probably looking forward
to our Sequel offering.
Alfred is, in his talk tomorrow, is gonna
show you ways that we are planning to make
querying on the Datastore much, much, much
better.
It's gonna reduce the number of indexes.
I don't wanna, I don't wanna spoil anything
but if you're--
[audience chuckles]
>>Max: you, you need to be at his talk. Ok?
>>Alfred: It's the last one tomorrow.
>>Max: But, it's the last talk tomorrow.
>>audience6: But, is, it--
>>Max: You should definitely come to his talk
tomorrow.
He's gonna, he's gonna shatter myths.
>>audience6: Ok.
[laughter]
>>Max: But the, the thing that you're running
up against is, is, is a fundamental limitation
of the guarantees that we give you with the
datastore, which is that we're not gonna pull
entire results that's in the memory, we're
not gonna do joins in memory.
There needs to be an efficient scan and in
order to line up those efficient scans, somebody
has to write the data.
And it's either going to be us on your behalf
through composite indexes or it's gonna be
you writing the data yourself when you're
denormalizing.
[pause]
>>Toby: I'm not a Datastore expert like Max,
but I was just gonna say quickly, that still
the number of reads compared to the number
of writes are like, usually, typically, order
of magnitude, like a thou-, several orders
of magnitude, like a thousand times or something.
And you can, and you can do your writes off
in like, task queues or things like, things
asynchronously or whatever.
And, whereas, like your reads, are often pretty
much a blocking in requests and whatnot.
So, usually still, you can optimize for your
reads and have your reads be very fast and
have your writes take longer, but off asynchronously.
[pause]
>>Sean: The next one is, "Can you guys talk
about what you learned from the downtime in
February? It was impressively handled."
Thank you.
"And would like some insight from your experience."
[pause]
Yeah, yeah.
>>Kevin: What was?
>>Sean: What did we learn from the downtime
in February?
>>Kevin: That's a good question.
I think, if you look at the post mortems that
we published, I hope they give you a hint
as the sort of stuff that we've learned from
that.
I think that's probably the best thing that
I can say.
There's, there's a lot in all of them.
And we, I think eat and breathe them so much
that it's, it's hard for me to suss them all
apart.
I think that one thing we have learned in
general, from a lot of these things are that
the more prepared we can be for however esoteric
a situation, the better we can build tools,
the better we can do everything.
It's something that always helps people who
administer systems, so, we're, we work on
that hard for preparedness, various disasters,
doing drills, simulating failures, a lot of
that.
I know Alfred was working on some of that
stuff earlier this week.
So, may-, that's one lesson that comes to
mind.
Anybody else wanna throw in something?
I, I would suggest, if you haven't already,
reading our post mortems.
We really try to share this with you so you
can see what it's like for us and how we're
trying to do that.
[pause]
Yeah, another question?
>>audience7: Hi, my company is just about
to embark on moving some applications to Google
Apps, and running them in parallel in fact
with our existing ones.
We have a fairly large number of rather hairy
Lotus Notes applications that we've been developing
for some time.
Now, so there are a couple of issues that
come up from that.
The first is, have you guys had an experience
with complicated app migration from Notes
or perhaps anyone else in the room who may
have some tools that we can use without having
to build ourselves?
And, if I can cram in a second part -- I hope
it's not divisive, my developers seem to think
they want to program in, in Java.
I, on the other hand, prefer the concision
and elegance of Python and I was wondering
if maybe there's at least one person on the
panel who might be willing to express some,
some views as to why Python might, might be
superior.
[audience laughs and claps]
>>Sean: So, let's tackle your first one.
[audience laughs]
Advice on migration from Lotus Notes applications.
Do we have any?
Yes.
>>Kevin: Oh, I don't know.
A part of the, I guess the interesting part
of our job is we don't know what apps most
of you guys have written about here.
The way we find out about apps are people
post in the groups, they tell us about it,
we hear from someone, a partner contacts us.
Occasionally we see apps if there's a, a problem
and we're helping someone with that.
So, I don't know, I mean, out of all the ones
that work I bet there have been some people,
but I don't really have a lot of data on it.
So--
>>Sean: Just out of curiosity, how many of
you in the crowd are dealing with Lotus Notes
applications that you really want to get rid
of?
Ok, so, a few of you.
All right.
And then the second question.
Oh, ok.
>>Brett: So, I know that they've done, I think
the Gmail guys have done some stuff with pulling
data out of Domino.
So, maybe you could track down a Gmail guy
and ask him what they've got.
Maybe they've got a parser in API or something
to just migrate data in and out of the, the
Domino server.
>>audience7: It's, it's not so much the data;
we can write that piece.
It's a, a somewhat painless migration of the
applications themselves--
>>Brett: Yeah, yeah, ok.
I don't have the answer to that.
[audience laughs and claps]
>>Guido: Rewrite the applications in Python.
[audience laughs]
I was actually gonna refer to Brett because
he wrote one of the fastest applications,
one of the most popular applications that
currently runs on App Engine, with the unpronounceable
name "PubSubHubbub" and guess which language
he used?
>>Brett: Yeah, I used Python.
I like, I like Python a lot.
I mean, Java people swear by Java, and I understand
the, why people write in Java.
Personally, I really like Python because it's
so brief and I write almost all my apps on
App Engine in Python, and I really try to
write my example code for talks in Java, but
then it doesn't fit on the slide and so--
[audience laughs]
and so, this talk this time, I really made
sure that you could implement everything in
Java if you wanted to, so there's no extra
missing bit.
But, but yeah, just, I still, I just, I can't,
I can't do it, now whereas Max--
[audience chuckles]
breathes Java all the time.
I think Don does, too.
I think Toby, also.
But, yeah, we got at least two advocates on
the team for Python.
>>audience7: Thank you.
>>Max: We all, we all get along really nicely.
[audience laughs]
It's kind of boring, actually.
>>Sean: Go ahead.
>>Mike: Hi, Mike Koss from a Seattle start-up,
called StartPad.
I have just, wonder if you could rate yourselves
on your overall service reliability over the
last year and I think when I, when I was very
eagerly one of your first adopters after the
first Campfire and, after the first year we
very much understood like, this is a Beta
program and scheduled maintenance outages,
and, and long query times and things like
that that occasionally popped up were kind
of expected.
But, I, I think I've been, I think when I've
been recommending App Engine to other people,
I love every aspect of it except I do have
to qualify I think when I, when I talk to
people, I say, "You know what? It's kind of
still feels a little Beta. It still feels
like it's not gonna be as reliable as you
might need for your application."
I'd, I'd like to bet-, to be someday not have
to be a qualified answer.
>>Sean: So, I think the question was, can
we give a rating of how our reliability has
been over the last, say, year?
And probably, as well, what are we doing to
address that?
>>Kevin: Well, that's a tough one.
I mean, a rating, I don't know how we would,
what we would say.
But, I guess the things that come to mind
for me are one, please bear with us.
These things, the first year as, like I heard
from you it was understandable.
Well, the second year we've grown a lot more.
So, it's, there's a lot for us to do and we
are trying our very best and we're, we're
all professionals here and, and we're trying
to do the best that we can about it.
With that said, I'm actually pretty proud
of our reliability.
It's terrible and it's hard raining for all
of us.
So, as you guys as users, and us as the people
who run the system, when we have an outage
and we have a problem, when you compare to
the typical things you might encounter in
standard hosting environments, I'm not sure
that we're all that much worse, if worse.
It's hard to say because there are no central
statistics collected on a dis-, dis-, distribution
of apps, right?
Let's say I was to take like a hundred thousand
apps used every week, out of the random cross
section in the Internet, how often do they
have errors, how often do they have problems?
How would we compare? I can't calculate that
number and I can't tell you so you can each
only reach your own conclusions.
So, it, sometimes part of the problem might
be that you see them a lot more with App Engine.
I, because we're under scrutiny. Google's
a big company, so you know about it, you can
read about it.
And, of course, I'm happy about that.
I, I partly don't like it, but I'm also happy
about it because I want to be honest, I want
to be transparent, so you guys know what's
going on.
But with other things, other systems, other
sites, smaller sites, other smaller hosting
providers, you might not know as much either.
So--
>>audience8: [inaudible]
>>Sean: How would you compare App Engine to
the search site or Gmail?
>>Kevin: Well, it's different than the search
site, I can tell you that.
[audience laughs]
I-, there are, there are big, different, I'm
sorry.
Big, order of magnitude scale differences
between the world's biggest Web product, right?
And what we're doing here with App Engine.
So, some of those things are different.
Of course, fundamentally, the problem that
we're trying to solve is a bit different,
too.
WebSearch is a single very, very tuned product.
A lot of us, in various forms, have contributed
to WebSearch before we worked on App Engine.
And when you're doing a very specific thing,
there's a lot of things that you can do to
sort of boost the reliability to make it better
that may be domain specific.
Nothing that we can do in App Engine is necessarily
domain specific.
We try to get you guys the tools to do that,
but I completely understand that it's hard
to spend a lot of engineering time on a tool
that'll help you for I, one-tenth of a percent
of the time that your app runs to handle those
situations. We do things like that for WebSearch,
though.
So, for instance, you guys know about the
capabilities API, or read-only periods, you
know about that.
We might have more things like that in the
future but I know it can be a lot of work
to add that functionality to your app to work
in those settings.
So, I'd say that might be something to compare
with, too.
We don't code your app; we can only host it.
So, some of those other features, we are not
in as much control as a single vertical.
>>audience8: [inaudible]
>>Kevin: I, well, I, I, I don't mean to be
rude but I just see all the other questions
coming, so I hate to see someone get interrupted.
>>audience9: [inaudible]
>>Max: Thank you.
>>Alon: Thanks.
>>Sean: I'm just gonna grab a question off
the Moderator and then we'll get you--
>>audiencemember: You should.
You should.
>>Sean: So, with the new pricing model what
are, let me see here, what are the approximate
limits on monthly bandwidth and storage?
And they give an example, "Can I upload five
terabytes on my data domain?"
>>Kevin: Sure.
So, you can read a lot more about this online.
There is a site published and hopefully it
has a lot of good answers to your questions.
To sort of piece apart your question a little
bit, you mentioned the limits on usage and
then you mentioned storage, I believe.
Storage is separate and so all of this is
still coming together now.
But when, when I spoke today about unlimited
and when we talk about that through usage,
what we're generally talk about is your online
usage.
Things, since many of you are very familiar
App Engine developers, things like your CPU
time and the bandwidth used, storage is a
separate resource.
We're still hammering out the details on exactly
how that will work, but it is not something
that we anticipate to be fully unlimited because
it, it just functions a little bit differently
in that setting.
>>Sean: Cool.
Go ahead.
>>Max: Oh, I'm Max.
So, it's somewhat related to the question
before this question, and it's, it's sort
of made-up question.
In, in, bear with me.
So, in, you, you guys are famous for dogfooding,
what this were, inventing this word for coining
it.
And it seems to me that App Engine is not
being dogfooded to the extent that, like for
instance, what you were saying before that
Gmail is sort of independent, I don't know
if it's running on App Engine, or if you want
to admit that or not admit that.
And it seemed that it's a lot of good frameworks
that, or, or systems are extracted based on
usage that you've had and then you realize
that it’s important maybe to generalize
a little bit.
And I thought you were doing this with App
Engine.
But, from the struggle from last year and
all the issues that you're finding, and all
the missteps and so on, I have a feeling that
maybe that's not what's happening, it's a
new product you're inventing, which is cool;
nothing wrong with that, but its, it, it creates
a whole set of issues because you'll make
missteps and you'll have to backtrace and
so on.
Am I, am I correct in saying this, or, or
am I wrong?
>>Sean: The question is, is Google being dogfooding
Google App Engine, essentially.
>>Max: And it, was it extracted, also? Was
it, was it something that was internally being
used, like for instance, Amazon, a lot of
their web service products were being used
internally, and then they exposed them.
>>Sean: Did, did App Engine, as a service,
come up organically or was it put together
as a separate service?
>>Kevin: Oh, well that's a fun background
question.
The App Engine service, the original project
came together organically.
There were some of us who worked at Google,
some of us who knew each other, some we had
a shared interest.
And we were interested in doing what App Engine
is, basically what you saw when it initially
launched.
So, we got together and sort of put it together
ourselves, started working on it and until,
and much later it, it was an actual product
and it launched.
And I think that's something really great
about Google.
Google really, I, I've been at Google for
a long time now.
It combines what I think in some cases, is
the best of both worlds in terms of top-down
and bottom-up.
So, there are a lot of great ideas that just
filter up from engineers who think of them
and what they want to do, and a great culture
saying, "Hey, well, you got an idea, make
a prototype."
If people like your prototype, you run with
it.
But there's also some things where we try
to from the top down say, "Hey, this seems
like an important space to be in and an important
thing to do."
So, I think App Engine though, when it got
started, it was one of the first ones.
>>Brett: I, I think also that it, it codifies
a lot of the internal best practices that
Googlers, like Kevin, who've been at the company
for a long time and, and a lot of our other
infrastructure engineers.
The best practices that they've gained over
time, we’ve taken those and applied them
to the infrastructure and then, now there's
a lot of internal apps and even external products
like Google Moderator and Fast Flip and PubSubHubbub
and more, that are being built on top of App
Engine by Googlers as Google products.
So, it’s, it's basically its like, it's
not just an extraction, like you were saying,
but it was extracting a, a set of best practices.
>>Max: But why is it so bad and Gmail is so
great?
[audience laughs]
I mean, I hate to say it that way, but it
seems like Gmail fails every now and then
but there's so many people using Gmail.
I love it, right?
But App Engine, I, I can't say that.
And I know it's a different thing, but if
I ran Gmail on top of App Engine, I imagine
it would fail also.
>>Brett: So that's a really difficult question,
like the way to phrase it.
I mean, I think that we do share a lot of
the same backend infrastructure, the same
datacenters, the same network infrastructure,
so a lot of the benefits, you know, it's a
big table and so like, a lot us we share a
lot of the same infrastructure.
So, a lot of the benefits you see in the speed
and scalability and distribution and isolation
of the problems and stuff like that, we get
kind of the same benefits.
Where you see some of the other kind of issues,
was what Kevin was getting back to which is
if you have a single vertical product, you
can really focus on a lot of tricks to make
sure that it has a higher level of reliability.
And so with App Engine, we have this, this
difficulty of saying, "We need to let you
do anything but also provide you with reliability."
And that's, it's the same trade-off where
it's not, it's not perfect, right?
And we started off with penalizing you if
you went more than three seconds on a request
and now you can burn 30 seconds, right?
So, we've taken, we've gone a long way to
give you more functionality to let you do
even more stuff whereas, we could have just
said, "Every request, when we started and
we launched, every request has to be less
than a second on average."
And, that's it; because that was the way we
could control the scalability and reliability,
right?
So, these things are at odds with each other
and I'm, I'm very happy with how far we've
come in the last two years to give, to give
more and more functionality while also increasing
our reliability.
So, I hope that's a good answer.
>>Troy: And, and to that point, it only has
been two years for us.
Sorry, I'm Troy Trimble.
I, I work on App Engine.
I'm a software developer.
Gmail's been out for six years now?
I think it was like April 2004 or something
like that?
So, I mean, time, you know?
Like, time in developers.
Give me three years -- I'll build something.
>>Max: Is it still in Beta, Gmail?
>>Troy: No, they're no longer in Beta.
[audience laughs]
>>Brian: On the dogfooding question, there
was an hour long talk on [inaudible] at 12:30
today.
>>Brett: That's Brian Berry, everybody. That's
all the team [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>audience8: I apologize if this was already
asked.
On the App Engine for Business, we're really
excited about just hearing the words SLA and
Sequel – it’s really just enough to make
the trip worthwhile.
But, the question is what you demonstrated
was an intranet based application platform
and most of the apps that we build have intranet
in different role components, but also have
customer facing components that we-, would
not authenticate to.
Is there a, a model where you can be able
to comingle in that space?
>>Sean: So, the, the question is will App
Engine for Business support external facing
applications?
You're correct.
It was asked before but not a problem.
Yes, is the answer to your question and we
can talk a little bit more afterwards.
I just don't wanna go into it too much.
>>audience9: This is for the –
So, the question I had was actually related
to a start-up request versus a normal request.
So, the question, actually, why can't a start-up
request actually happen even before the first
call to an instance is made.
For example, now a case like we have now heavy
Java spring applications and only the start-up
request usually exceed the first 30 second
deadline in the exception.
>>Sean: So the, the question is why do we,
why don't we initialize runtimes before we
actually send a user request to them?
Why is the user request also the loading request?
>>Kevin: So, I guess the, the quickest answer
to it is we serve a lot of apps.
If we need to initialize something for you
for your request, you're gonna wait one way
or the other because your app is different
from all the other apps.
So, that happens a lot and we are working
on some of the things I was mentioning before.
We're working on ways to make this better;
ways to hide that time from you.
But, a lot of those things will, or, have
to do with reserving things for you, bulking
things in advance, so that, that work has
been done in advance for you.
That changes a bit about the platforms so
that's why some of these changes are taking
a while to get to you.
>>audience9: Ok, thanks.
[pause]
>>Burke: I'm Burke Floyd.
I work for Jardon Howard Technologies.
I had two quick questions.
One is, do you guys plan on adding support
for say NetBeans, plugins for other developer
tools to make it easier to work in those environments?
And the second question is, is, has there
been any new work for, maybe related to his
question, migrating some Google Apps or Google
products towards using App Engine?
Is that in the progress, like any major tools
or major apps that you might be moving that
way, or have we seen some other than maybe
PubSubHubbub or something like that?
>>Sean: So, the first question, can you repeat
that again, I, I--
>>Burke: The NetBeans, maybe NetBeans support
or other development tools?
>>Sean: Plugins for other, yeah.
>>Max: For NetBeans, we don't, we don't have
any specific plans for that.
We have, we, we developed the Eclipse plugin.
There's an IntelliJ plugin which works great,
which I use all the time which was developed
by the the IntelliJ folks.
Our approach, our general approach so far
has been we do, we do the, you know, we're
invested in the Eclipse platform and we do
the development there and we're happy for
other, other development teams to, to, to
match us and exceed us wherever they feel
it's necessary.
>>Don: There is actually a NetBeans plugin
that, that someone, I think someone at Sun
implemented, right?
>>Toby: I'm not, I'm not sure about Sun, but--
>>Don: Yeah, yeah.
Or Oracle, whatever.
At the time it was called Oracle.
So, there's one and w-, we haven't talked
to the person.
I personally haven't tried it.
We can't, I think we actually mention it in
our documentation now.
So, but yeah, it's, it's out there and was
done completely without our help because we've
made this public tools API that any tools
developer can take advantage of.
>>Toby: Right, yeah, so I was gonna say the
same thing.
We actually have a tools API and, and they
have gone out and that's what the IntelliJ
plugin is based off of.
That's what the NetBeans plugin is based off
of.
But, but we're actually even going a step
further in that we have a plan, like we've
been talking about taking the, the code that
we have for the Eclipse plugin and making
that open source and even, and even going
a step further on top of that and trying to
orient that code for the Eclipse plugin such
that it could be used like, used from other,
for, for other plugins and other IDEs.
So, so yeah, we're not directly doing anything
for NetBeans, but we're indirectly trying
to make more and more of our code usable by
other IDEs.
>>Max: So, what was the second question, again?
>>Burke: Basically, have you guys seen anything
over the last year, let's say--
>>Max: Internal apps.
>>Burke: The major projects
>>Max: Or the Googlers using App Engine for,
for Google stuff, right?
>>Burke: Right.
>>Max: So, I think, I think what Ryan was
saying before--
>>unknown: [inaudible]
>>Max: Yeah, migrations.
So, I think you should definitely find the
video of the talk that Ben Fried, our CIO,
gave today.
It was earlier in the day and he talks about
the apps they're building and migrating, specifically
internal apps.
And that's the, been, the first focus on a
lot of these things.
So, I would definitely check that out and,
and, I don't remember if he talks about externalized
products also, but that's like, probably the
best resource for that.
>>Sean: I'm gonna grab one of the, the Moderator.
So, how does up-, App Engine uptake over the
last few years in terms of types of scale
of application, fit with your original expectations
of App Engine?
>>Kevin: Well, I don't know. I'll just give
an answer.
[pause]
I think App Engine has grown a lot more than
we thought.
As, as I mentioned in the keynote today, half
a billion page views, if you count page views,
that, that's daily page views, if you count
page views, that's a lot.
So, that's been more growth than I expected
or I think a lot of us would have expected
and that happened pretty quickly.
In terms of number of apps, we see all sorts.
We see a lot of really big apps, we see a
lot of medium size apps, we see a lot of apps
that based on how we think about things at
Google, how we measure scale, which is in
these crazy big numbers because Google tends
to do these really big products that we don't
think about enough.
But we have a huge middle ground of these
apps that just have a lot of regular usage.
And so, that's been a little surprising to
me.
There's been a lot more of sort of the long
tail than I would've thought.
What about you guys, any thoughts?
>>Max: I was just gonna say that in general;
we don't know what you're doing with us.
Your apps are out there and most of the time,
unless you're driving like huge numbers of
traffic, or you're getting errors and your
posting on the message groups, if you're a
happy customer, we don't generally know what
you're doing.
We don't know what domain your application
is running in.
We don't know how much data you're storing.
We don't have a good sense of how much traffic
it's driving, unless it's really sort of at
the upper end of things.
So, I don't know.
I think, I think that's a nice attribute of
it; that we’ve just got a big melting pot
of applications.
>>Brett: I'd say all that's true, and then
mobile, mobile games, I just keep hearing
from developers they're building backends
for mobile apps and mobile games on top of
App Engine because it has these great scaling
properties.
And, more and more people we run into are
doing that and finding success with it, which
is really great because they see the problem,
they, a lot of them are bootstrap startups,
finally got their stuff to the App Store,
don't have a hundred thousand dollars to sink
on servers and need to support 30 thousand
users tomorrow.
And then, so it, it's great to be able to
solve this problem for them of, of really
quickly scaling.
>>Kevin: And now, I, I think that we have
to wrap up now because the sessions over.
But, let me tell you this, we're all here.
We've got a big office space that's right
up the escalator and we're around for the
whole conference.
I would love to answer every single question.
I know all of these guys would, too.
So please track us down, come to the office
space, ask us your questions, and I'd love
to talk to all you guys more.
Thank you for your time.
[applause]